dès le 1er janvier prochain vous le
savez maintenant tous les chauffeurs de
taxi de montréal devront soumettent
devront se soumettre de nouvelles règles
faudra ouvrir la porte aux clients les
clients qu'on va chercher à la maison
pas les clients qui elle un taxi dans la
rue mais c'est aussi un taxi vient vous
chercher à la maison le chauffeur devra
sortir de la voiture et ouvrir la porte
être habillés en noir et blanc et c'est
accepter le paiement électronique ça
c'est déjà fait depuis deux semaines
maintenant en principe jean-sébastien
c'est vraiment un grand grand ménage que
l'on veut faire dans l'industrie du taxi
way et jusqu'en 2016 2017 on va
continuer de faire des changements
talent et par là des chauffeurs
aujourd'hui patrice sur le terrain on
est conscient qu'il faut améliorer
l'image
on est conscient qu'à bien des égards
faut améliorer le service à certains
règlements qui passent mieux d'autre
part les de l'uniforme on trouve que
blanc c'est un peu salissant mais on est
d'accord les caméras à bord on est
d'accord ouvrir la portière aux
passagers cela dit ça on trouve ça
beaucoup trop exagérer bien que le
bureau du taxi nous disent que ça existe
pas plus loin qu'à ottawa cette
réglementation là je vous laisse là
dessus écoutez des chauffeurs de taxi de
façon générale on n'est pas très content
la pression est d'autant plus sur le
chauffeur de taxi qui était en train de
paix de l'industrie et on exige encore
davantage d'autres réglementations
surtout vers les portières avec moins 40
de la place lâche ça devient peu
dangereux pour nous aussi veut veut pas
nous pour leur tenue vestimentaire ça ça
me dérange pas tout au contraire c'est
bien ça donne ça de la patience et plus
plus acceptable pour la société façon de
plus pour nous humilier
c'est tout simplement ça parce que déjà
ils nous font tellement de mal avec et
tout règlement qui est déjà bon mais du
côté des clients
certains pourraient répondre aux
derniers monsieur dernier chauffeur
si vous avez tant mal c'est que les gens
vous ont délaissé parce qu'on trouvait
dans certains cas les voitures n'étaient
pas pratiquer cet art etc
alors vous avez rencontré des clients
toutes sortes de réponses bien sûr on
connaît le contexte ans de plus en plus
de gens prennent
bref cette entreprise de covoiturage
commercial hubert d'autres trouvent que
ça ils sont donc content mais donc
trouve que ça va un peu trop loin qu'on
n'est pas obligé d'aller jusque là
voici donc quelques personnes
rencontrées ça laisse à désirer dans la
propreté des véhicules et des chauffeurs
aussi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
pour les texans n'ont rien juste un
décorum ça s'en remettait plus
intéressant parce qu'on est là pour
avoir la plus professionnelle je connais
des gens moi qui tu dises hubert
justement parce que ils ont pas de
problème
c'est un peu exagéré là pour c'est pas
des chauffeurs privés là ce sont des
taxis mais jma fou mais qu'est ce qui
est dommage chauffeur de taxi je veux
savoir que les pois sous pli c'est
conduire alors au bureau du taxi de
montréal
on nous dit qu'on va accompagner
informer les chauffeurs dans cette
transition il y aura éventuellement un
fonds de créer pour les aider à payer
par exemple aider les propriétaires à
payer des caméras à bord mais pas
question de retourner en arrière les
chauffeurs d'une respecteront ça passe
ça pour avoir des annonces ou à un
simple histoire de la porte on va mettre
un peu d'eau dans son vin là on sent que
le pendule va vraiment de l'autre côté
tel savoir arrêter au milieu on verra on
verra
j'enseigne merci